ich bin sauer als ich
mich dann jo
was geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen Video natürlich
von euch erinnern sich vielleicht noch
ein Video das ist schon ewig her da habe
ich mal so einen Tag oder eine Woche
Automaten getestet das waren aber so
Standard Dinger und ich habe letztens
ein Video von dem Amerikaner gesehen der
hat Automaten dachte ich mir
das wird nicht so krass aber hier muss
es doch auch coole Automaten geben Pizza
Automaten Automaten Automaten das 3.
jetzt glaube ich weg das werde ich nicht
finden aber ich habe ein paar coole
Automaten na gut gerade ist es erst
einer muss ich ehrlich sein das ist ein
Pizza Automat der befindet sich in
Dortmund da fahren wir jetzt gleich mal
hin und ich bin gespannt wie da die
Pizza schmeckt also wirklich Pizza aus
dem Automaten raus und dann habe ich
euch noch auf meinem Instagram Account
gefolgt Leute kennt ihr coole abgespaced
Automaten wo es außergewöhnliche Sachen
geschickt die mir bitte am besten aus
NRW damit wir da heute mal hinfahren
können deswegen heute bin ich viel im
Auto und Untersetzer jetzt natürlich auf
euch erstmal geht es allerdings nach
Dortmund ich bin heiß und ich hoffe es
wird geil Leute viel Spaß bei dem Video
und ab ins Auto let's go bevor wir
starten gehe noch mal schauen voraus und
ecovacs vielen Dank hab wieder neue
Saugroboter bzw wir können schon das ist
der Tee noch ein Ei wie ich online heute
netterweise noch mal das Video und ich
darf euch noch einmal den T9 Idol
vorstellen ein absolut top Saugroboter
mit den neuesten Features dieses Ding
kann quasi alles was es so auf dem Markt
bis jetzt gibt was ich noch mal ganz
besonders herausstellen möchte ist dass
dieses Ding über künstliche Intelligenz
dafür und wirklich eine hochauflösende
integrierte Kamera hat das erstmal ganz
gut weil dann werden sämtliche Objekte
umfahren ihr könnt aber auch von egal wo
ihr seid auf den Saugroboter zugreifen
und schauen was bei euch zu Hause gerade
so abgeht durch da wird mir einfallen
wenn ihr ein Haustier zu Hause habt und
ich wüsste ok Piste mir jetzt die Bude
voll oder nicht kann man mal vielleicht
mal reinschauen. Ich benutze jetzt schon
wirklich lange ecovacs Saugroboter aber
was bei diesem Modell ganz besonders ist
dieses Teil hat Verwicklung freie
Bürsten das heißt früher wurde auf Kabel
Haare was auch immer rein gesaugt und
irgendwann musstest du das rein oder das
Ding hat sich aufgehangen das kann es
sicher passieren und das ist wirklich
ein enormer Vorteil ich will euch gar
nicht mit irgendwelchen Fachwörter
nerven aber du Messing System und
Lasersensoren das heißt erstmal eure
Wohnung wird komplett eingescannt jeder
Raum wird automatisch als neuer Raum
zugewiesen wir können quasi auch nur
einzelne Räume dann säubern lassen so
kann es aussehen und mit der
integrierten Lasertechnik egal ob es
dunkel oder hell ist scheißegal ihr
könnt den Sauger immer losschicken und
wirklich Leute ich kann immer nur in den
besten Tönen von ergobag sprechen die
sind wirklich gut die Dinger ich habe
bei mir hier ein ich habe einen Büro und
was für eine kurz zeigen weil ich habe
gestern zwei Freunde von mir so ein
bisschen ja was heißt wenn ich sage
geprankt aber die Kameratechnik und auch
die Sprachsteuerung immer so ein
bisschen vorgeführt
was das denn Alex das Ding Video von mir
[Musik]
Leute kurze Planänderung bzw ich weiß
gar nicht wann was zuerst kommt und
welche Automaten ich jetzt chronologisch
schon gecheckt habe es ist doch alles
ein bisschen schwieriger als gedacht wir
fahren jetzt nach Lage da hat mich
nämlich einer von euch drauf hingewiesen
und zwar gibt es dort einen
nudelaufläufe Pasta Automaten würde ich
mir gerne anschauen deswegen ab nach
Lage wie ist die Lage der Gang gute Lage
ab nach Lage gleich Leute was geht wir
sind jetzt hier in Lage vielleicht ist
er automatisch auf draußen ist er gut
booknis Automat frisch und lecker steht
da dran, hier ist noch KFC
irgendwie gar nicht gut aus
zumindest
will ich unbedingt
ich habe nur eine Frage wisst ihr ob sie
irgendwie passt da Automaten gibt ein
Automat wo man so essen kaufen kann
passt da Automat nein ne okay ciao ich
bin sauer als solches kann wirklich
nicht sein ne schon einmal war das der
mieseste Flop und jetzt schon wieder
Leute wenn ihr ein Automat kennt
irgendwo in Deutschland am besten in NRW
geile Automaten vielleicht gibt es auch
einfach nicht nehmen für mich übel ich
habe alles versucht dieses Video
wirklich ich habe so oft irgendwo
hingefahren und auf dem Wald das geht
einfach nicht klar jo Leute was geht bin
gerade extra Dortmund gefahren um mir
mal diesen Pizza Automat zu checken wenn
der jetzt nicht funktioniert dieses
Video ich mache es nicht fertig ich
werde dann so sauer sein sieht so aus
als funktioniert ja geil ich habe sowas
noch nie gesehen ne 4 Minuten warum ist
denn der Automat nicht so beliebt Hague
geilo meilo Alter die Schnelle Pizzeria
schnellste PC zum Aufbacken zum
Reinbeißen U4 Minuten also bei mir im
Backofen dauert das ein bisschen länger
als vier Minuten da bin ich mal gespannt
ob wie schmeckt ok fahren Sie ohne Konto
Ford Salami Calabrese was nehmen wir
denn Margarita näheres auch were none
will ich auch nicht 94 RC finde
Tiefkühlpizza Margarita herkommen ich
muss Margarita nebenbei den Rest esse
ich nicht so gerne bestellen was zu
trinken gibt sie nicht oder stetigen Sie
die Bestellung zahlen dann halte ich
jetzt mein Kärtchen dran Girocard
Zahlung erfolgt also da muss ich sagen
bin ich jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was
rauskommt tschüss auf 4 Minuten warten
und meine Tiefkühlpizza ist fertig oder
wird die krank aufge Hitze drin weil wie
soll die in 4 Minuten fertig werden und
hier kommt ihr dann wahrscheinlich raus
ne Schwäche gehe nicht ich bin gespannt
ey so Leute hier geht der Countdown
runter noch 40 Sekunden dann kommt meine
Pizza raus und was man sagen muss wie
riecht schon nach Pizza also ich habe
hier wirklich so eine Pizza geholt da
mir hier entgegenkommt woraus auch immer
wahrscheinlich aus dem Kartenfach lecker
ich hoffe für dich du bist geschnitten
liebe Pizza oh
mein Gott dkctf geil hallo weiß ich
nicht das hätte ich jetzt mal
ich
muss sagen das finde ich schon sehr nice
dieses Konzept dass sie dann wirklich in
sieht sehr hochwertig aus da gebe ich
dann gerne auch mal
ich finde Margarita Pizza von Dr Oetker
auf einer muss ja schon sagen im Laden
kostet die glaube ich bei Euro 29 und da
dann halt 94 ist schon ein krasser
Unterschied und ich weiß noch nicht so
ganz was ich von dem Konzept halten soll
vollständig mal vor da stehen fünf Leute
an die alle eine Pizza wollen dann musst
du halt kurz Kopfrechnen 20 Minuten
warten aber ich könnte jetzt erstmal
zurück ins Auto weil das steht im
absoluten Halteverbot und dann essen wir
mal eben scheiße jetzt habe ich gar kein
Getränk und Getränke fehlen auch noch in
eurem Automaten bitte noch nach Rust
oder Getränkeautomaten daneben stellen
danke so Leute was geht
zurück im Auto evoila dann würde ich
sagen schreib mal das mal ab
so sieht die aus ne ich hatte mich sehr
über Sonne ich hätte mich wohl wobei nee
nee nee das ist safe nicht die gleiche
Pizza wie aus dem Supermarkt die ist ein
bisschen größer und guck mal wann kann
es glaube ich gut oder ich weiß es nicht
genau könnt ihr mal in die Kommentare
schreiben wenn ihr euch aus junge jetzt
bleib doch mal hier stehen du scheiß
Karton die ist schon so ein bisschen
fluffiger einfach ne sonst die
Tiefkühlpizzen die sind ja hart wie ein
Brett eigentlich ne dann würde ich sagen
weiß ich mal rein kleiner Kritikpunkt
oder was heißt klein einge schon groß
wie willst du die wenn du unterwegs bist
schneiden geht ja nicht das müsste man
eigentlich safe noch integrieren dass
diese Pizza auch im Automaten noch
geschnitten wird weil so ist das
natürlich ein bisschen kompliziert ich
könnte die naja probieren wir mal
schön heiß ist ich warte mich wirklich
wie wir das Dingen innerhalb von 4
Minuten fertig schon krass wie malt man
ein bisschen reißen hier wirklich lecker
also ich war auf jeden Fall schon in
Pizzerien wo die Pizza frisch belegt
wurde in Ofen gesteckt wurde auf meinen
Teller und die man dann trotzdem wegen
die schlechter als diese hier aber
natürlich ist das jetzt keine Weltklasse
Pizza an der das ist klar sie schmeckt
gut wir für eure 90 kannst du nicht
meckern ja das muss ich sagen also der
aus blockieren hat sich gelohnt
Erfahrung er Leute was geht was soll ich
sagen ich bin mittlerweile wieder zu
Hause es ist so viel schwerer als
gedacht als ich habe wirklich gedacht
wenn ich euch Frage es jetzt helfe auch
in Deutschland so viele geile Automaten
geben die ich mal testen kann vielleicht
jetzt hier noch mal durch das
Youtube-Video werden ja noch mal mehr
Menschen erreicht wenn ihr welche kennt
hat mir super gehen auf insta schick mir
ein Foto da irgendwelche abgespaced and
zocken Automaten sowie Teufel der Pizza
Automat dann kann ich mir vorstellen
dass ich vielleicht öfter mal so ein
Video mache die verrücktesten Automaten
Deutschland da muss man halt einfach mal
ins Ausland da habe ich aber Lust drauf
und das ist auf jeden Fall für dieses
Jahr geplant trotzdem Finanzwirt
zuschauen ich hoffe ihr seid alle super
ins neue Jahr gekommen ich wünsche euch
allen nur das Beste und du mir sicher
dass 2022 auch für mich was YouTube
angeht wieder ein bisschen cooler wird
als ob Sätze ja da war ja nicht ganz so
aktiv aber ich habe viel geplant und
damit wird cool Leute bleibt schön dabei
V3 und danke für Alles ciao